[Music]
there was a weird moment during one of
yesterday's games some of you probably
saw it some viewers actually were
offended by announcer Kevin Harlan who
at the end of the Syracuse Virginia game
announced that Syracuse was back from
the dead on Easter Sunday
that's what he said I heard about that
I'm Catholic I didn't mind you know I'm
like okay whatever then I checked it out
for myself I listened to it again and I
agree he went a little too far
take a look back from the dead on Easter
Sunday I'm reminded of the Bible Luke 24
5 through 7 why do you look for the
living among the dead he is not here
risen remember how he told you all he
was still with you in Galilee the Son of
Man must be delivered over to the hands
of sinners be crucified and on the third
day be raised again is what Syracuse and
jimbe
Oh Lord
[Applause]
you